hmm
no there
[Music]
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to demon Moon
welcome to demonologist I am on the main
menu I think so there's plenty of these
games since phasmaphobia came out but
this is one of them that actually can be
played by one person meaning me because
I don't have any friends
and also I I don't have time to schedule
with other people I can't be bothered
about that but it promises that you can
play with one person
yeah I don't know is that a cockroach
why is there a [__] I don't know
anything about this game and I don't
know how to play it what is with that
painting
good God so maybe if it's any good I'll
actually play with a couple friends of
mine but for now
I'm just gonna explore it on my own no
Reflections what
is that supposed to imply okay whatever
I'm gonna get into the game now because
I think I want to know
ah there we are how to play as your
sanity decreases the ghost will become
more aggressive
ghosts will leave electromagnetic fields
oh my God it's much like phasmaphobia
but I don't need to know anything I
don't need to know anything to be able
to play this game so that's exactly what
I'm gonna do not know anything so very
much like phasmaphobia and that you get
your load out and then you go in or
probably I'm going to lose everything
but I'm going to the abandoned house
I'm ready
start
all right
interesting well I'm definitely going to
need a flashlight because it's probably
dark and this thing looks important I
want the
that's concerning
um and then I got this weird light
nope I'm full
I I'm gonna wave a cockroach around and
hope for the best that usually works out
well for me
uh-huh oh
detect the type of ghost
tablet J to select Ghost type case 6367
Barry Hendricks even if someone is next
to you it will respond
okay so I just got to find out what the
ghost is
uh
I only have one camera
I'm doing just fine
I have a cockroach
all right
whoa brewskies
nope I'm not that much of a coward
all right is this the abandoned house or
is the abandoned ounce Over Yonder way
well that's not a good sign
I don't care who you are you you go up
to someone's house and you see us skull
and some meat
that's not a good house
all right the Cockroaches
moving only when I move that's weird
oh okay
ah someone was kind enough to set up a
generator
hello
anybody here
oh that's lovely love your Decor oh
that's horrible
okay
oh hi why so many statues
also this place looks Vaguely Familiar
why does this look familiar
what is on the bed up there
I remember
where'd my cockroach go
well oh lamp okay
yeah no this is
who
Marcus Aurelius was that you
no this is ringing a bell about a horror
game then I played a while ago and I
don't know why would you do that
what is that even supposed to be uh my
cockroach
oh everything
hi
I got bad vibes I got bad vibes all over
the place
getting a lot of bad Vibe readings do
you want to play with me yeah kinda
I mean
yeah that's why I'm here I got a
cockroach you lacked bugs
haha
well I hate it in here
but uh you know it is what it is
and um
what was that supposed to be what are
you doing up down there hands off the
dress
you think that you're gonna get away
with whatever the hell you're doing
the answer is probably no
what is this a grimoire
whoa
I think wait
what in the Disney's Haunted Mansion
what I don't even understand what
they're supposed to be Victoria okay so
I'm starting to suspect that it might be
Victoria
I want to see a Victoria around here hmm
well it's very much like phasmaphobia
but I don't know what's gonna give me
any advice
all right might as well keep looking
around
I'm definitely not gonna die oh there's
power right there was a generator set up
I should have known that
okay
well that's at least halfway decent
why
Magna
yeah okay
oh
it's a dog
it's really dark in here
light switch oh thank you oh that's much
worse oh I'm glad I did that
know why
huh
oh cool very fun
okay so that was unhelpful I didn't
learn anything from my Excursion and I
feel worse about myself I have not been
turning on any of the lights I don't
know why I didn't even realize that was
an option
it's been fumbling around
you son of a [__]
that was too real of a screen
I don't know if you guys even think that
was a real scream it was very different
from like probably in the description
I don't know just caught me mid-breath
at the wrong time what are these
supposed to be
oh this is fine
yeah it's fine
[Music]
all right cool
oh good a workshop I think light
right
you just gotta sing
am I in danger usually in like
phasmaphobia this means I'm about to die
apparently not
but apparently everything's okay I think
oh
okay well that's unfortunate for me oh
that's a problem
hello
doing something fun over there
okay now leave that on
I thought
that this
was
um
just gonna be unless these are all just
random things occurring which they might
be hate that pot but it seems to be uh
some events
are happening
um
wonderful
really
oh oh oh cockroach is getting reading oh
my God
what do I do about that am I about to
die
light
hello
ah
[Music]
I'm going upstairs I'm not dealing with
any of this I'm not dealing with none of
that I'm dealing with a zero of all that
it
[__] what is why
no light in the bathroom it's just one
of those dark bathrooms
to build your character
put some hair on your chest
oh
oh oh
who did that
who did that there aren't that many
doors up here
I don't care what Ralph says
oh doors and dead boy
oh what is happening
I don't like it I'll do
oh
what in the world
what are you doing
oh
well I'm getting the EMF of four but
it's not quite five so I'm not impressed
you want to impress me you get up to
five then I'll be scared then I'll be
really scared uh this is a fun basement
any lights down here or no God this
flashlight sucks if only I had friends
with other beams of light
but I don't
I'm all alone why is there a light on
down here why is it a weird light what's
up with that light
something spooky about this light
I was right
that's a weird light
I don't know what that was all about
hi did someone die in this chair is
someone about to die in this chair
probably
also what does this do
hmm I don't know about this one
I'm not so sure I like my trusty
cockroach
all right hello
ah you're full of skulls great good
rate oh you're not a statue at all
didn't I see you upstairs
weren't you upstairs doing the whole
spook thing
why are you being a bit of a bastard to
me
all right
well
that was fun
but uh I think we can confirm that
there's no hauntings here
who's opening a door down there
hmm
no oh my God
well I uh I think it's time for me to go
um but before I go I need to punch a
ghost in the face
um
teach it some manners who Do You Think
You Are
hmm
oh we got five
five
well that's good then oh
five okay well that's that's good
all right so I got a reading of five
no I don't know what this thing do
I don't know if there's any guides that
I can use but I guess I could walk
around and look at things I suppose
maybe I should go out and change for
more well
okay I'm leaving now I'm gonna go change
out for more equipment you don't mind if
I leave do you
you don't mind if I just uh skedaddle or
doozy
yep I can tell this uh
it's not haunted
not at all not not haunted how do I drop
something there we go uh what are you
hello is it radio
maybe I want this this thing whatever
this is
Gizmo
yeah I have no idea how's my sanity fine
very good actually
extremely good
I'm gonna go zap them You Wanna Get
Zapped Anybody Wanna Get Zapped
oh really those just don't work set up
upable can I up ease that no I can't
help use that nah prepare to receive
electricity
hey bud who's in here
show me something
oh God
don't do that those are fragile
so it seems like there's something in a
bed some whoa thought that was a thing
this is the painting there's something
in a bed somewhere I just don't know
where that somewhere is
because it's kind of convoluted and
backwards here and some of the paths are
closed off let me just talk on the radio
anybody there
hello do I need to hook up my micro
under this thing is it like voice
sensitive
hello
how are you
man let me make sure that my input is
open mic uh we're gonna go with whoa uh
oh crashing
I need to restart the game for them oh
well it doesn't work right now
hello no it doesn't I need to restart
the game
whoa something's happening
what
foreign
I'm dead all right okay
um
case report find the human silhouette
using the ectoplasm glass exorcism
penalty 30 Ghost type detected Insurance
payback I got no money
I got nothing I did exactly dick wow
okay let me actually read over this just
to see if I'm doing some stupid EMF I
figured that out okay ESG by reacting to
the energy produced by the ESG you can
use this to detect the type of ghost G
button turn I never got any of that
flashlight that's basic okay easel ah
interesting Ecto glass okay ectoplasm
stain that's gross UV light oh that's
probably handy uh crucifix
thermometer I think just my breath who
needs a thermometer sanity pills yeah
right haven't had lot down in them since
amnesia
uh tripod camera that's obvious okay
well let me just restart the game real
quick so I can yell at some ghosts all
right I'm gonna try this again now I
might be slightly not excessively but
slightly less stupid all right so
hopefully it's not the same scares as
before but I have a funny feeling it
might be
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
start out obviously I'm going to get a
flashlight I'm going to get the UV light
for ectoplasm and I'm going to talk to
it on the Spirit Box hello
hello able to hunt some ghosts can't
wait to meet some ectoplasmic buddies of
mine
that's nice so do you think you died in
like a stupid way or a funny way or like
a stupid funny way you know what I mean
like when you died when you died
prematurely you remember that dying well
I want to talk about that I'm sure you
have some unfinished business hello oh
you're not going to do the same thing
again
interesting well I'm uncomfortable now
I'm very uncomfortable now
I'm I'm a lot I'm a lot less comfortable
I'm extremely uncomfortable actually
could you stop laughing at me
okay
all right
any ectoplasmic uh remains
go go of any kind
is your name Magna
I missed it do it again oh what was your
Magna
huh oh wait it's gone
the words wait a minute
Victoria
oh
[__]
oh don't like that hi
I have you well okay um
I don't know about this one guys I don't
know if I want to read the anger I think
I'm gonna
unless I just said the word
huh dream
oh yeah that's weird
[Music]
Celine Dion corfin
Kalyn down
Sim Moon
Simon I don't know what to do about this
I'm gonna go out and say angry
let's see what happens
anger
anger angry why are you angry huh you
got too much anger in your bones huh you
a piss baby you'll piss baby anger
we got glowy eyes
nope nothing
all right little wimpy babies
I hate you
wait what was that
what
oh
you're stupid
you're a ghost
what was that ugly
uh did you say let's stop Dan
what is your name how did you die
subscribe to Markiplier
anger
nope yep
did you say you will never vote for me
uh give me a sign
a sign I did that
I hate you
oh that looks fun
well goodbye
oh I seem to remember this might be bad
news oh well
Ah that's
well surely counteract that one hmm
I hope that didn't seem good
aggressive huh okay
angel
that might be good
flame of fate
I don't know what these are doing
aggressive yeah right
uh death well probably not good
void okay well I'm not seeing nothing
well
I'm not sure what killed me but I'm dead
anyway this is Ben
what is this called again demonologist
demonologist so obviously this game is
better with uh friends so what I'm going
to do is I'm gonna go find some friends
and then I'm gonna come back to this
because I like phasmaphobia but I also
like this one a bit it's it's got some
uh different Spooks but also I haven't
played phasmaphobia in a while and I
miss playing with my buddies we have
been doing a lot of distractible and go
so check those out if you haven't
already we've been doing video episodes
on Spotify you can find it by searching
for distractible on Spotify or there's a
link I don't know but if you want to go
listen to some fun stories between me
and my friends go to that and then if
you do that then we'll come back and
we'll play more demonologist but only if
you do that and phasmaphobia and Sons of
the forest and also finish raft but only
if you listen to the podcast thank you
and as always I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]